come on man please if we ever got the
chance to make a venom movie together
that would be super cool but his movie
would have to take place in the MCU
because I'm not giving up my ticket
welcome back everyone its charlie
everyone's still high on spider-man
views because the news he's staying in
the MCU for the next couple of films
within all that news is details about
what's going on with the spider-man
character in the next couple of movies
in the MCU but also spider-man in the
venom movies like venom 2 which they're
getting ready to shoot at the end of
November so if it wasn't clear Tom
Hollands spider-man will cross over into
the venom movies but we'll break it all
down we're doing a new round of that
spider-man far from home blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
spider-man 3 theories on the video
here's the quote from Kevin Feige
yesterday that lets you know about how
he's crossing over into the venom movies
so he says I'm thrilled this
spider-man's journey in the MCU will
continue because they signed the new
agreement and I and all of us at Marvel
Studios are very excited that we get to
keep working on it
this is the part where he talks about
him crossing over into the sonne venom
movies he says he also happens to be the
only hero with a superpower to cross
cinematic universes so as Sony continues
to develop their own Spidey verse you
never know what surprises the future
might hold there were a lot of news
outlets that jumped on this and assumed
that that meant that Kevin Feige would
be writing spider-man out of the MCU
with spider-man 3 in Avengers 5 so I'll
explain what the actual details of the
new sharing contract are what that means
for spider-man beyond Avengers 5 and
Beyond venom 2 there are two major
things that are happening under the
terms of this new Marvel Sony contract
first big thing is that Marvel will make
spider-man 3 and put spider-man in one
big crossover Marvel movie like Avengers
5 Fantastic Four
or any other movie that they want that
isn't a spider-man solo film the reason
why the next Avengers movie is just the
safest bet is because the whole point of
bringing him into the MCU in the first
place / Kevin Feige going back to
Captain America Civil War was to have
him interacting with as many of the
other Marvel characters as possible this
is him literally saying that the whole
point the whole point is spider-man is
inspired
unless he spider-men in in the in the
Marvel Universe yeah we wanted for the
first time to see him interact because
when Stan Lee and Steve Ditko created
spider-man he wasn't the only superhero
on that world he wasn't by himself in
New York City he was one of things that
made him you know the the what what he
became which was the icon of the company
the greatest comic character is he was
so different than those other heroes and
when there aren't those other heroes you
don't quite get spider-man to be what
spider-man is and then we could cast a
kid that was so different you know then
we could cast a kid who who was a kid
and that was what was so important about
finding Tom Holland is that we were
gonna put him in this world with all
these gods and grownups so just in terms
of sheer quantity Avengers movies have
the greatest number of different people
for spider-man to interact with but
Marvel hasn't put a date on Avengers 5
yet safest bet is it will be Marvel
phase 5 although its plugin happened
around the time they reboot Fantastic
Four which puts it somewhere around 2022
2023 probably not till after they start
to introduce the concepts of x-men and
Fantastic Four in the MCU the second
part of the new Marvel Sony contract is
even bigger but somehow not that many
people are talking about it so for the
duration of the next two Spider Man
appearances in the MCU movies give or
take the next four years or so however
long it takes to make those two movies
Marvel will have a 25% participation in
all of Sony's spider-verse and venom
movies that means that they'll fund 25%
of the cost to make all of Sony's movies
based on spider-man characters that
includes the venom movies the animated
Spider Man into the spider verse movies
in any other spin-offs that they do with
other sinister six villains but only for
the next four years or so that doesn't
mean that venom is in the MCU for the
next four years even though there will
be spider-man venom crossover before
that four years is up it just means that
Marvel and Disney will pay 25 percent of
the cost to make all those movies and
then potentially receive 25% of the
box-office profits on the back end after
Sony takes out its fees both Marvel and
Sony said that they might extend their
deal again after this next four to five
year period is up but for right now
they're mostly just on a movie to movie
basis when it comes to spider-man in the
MCU
[Applause]
[Music]
so this morning you probably saw all
kinds of people in your feed talking
about how Kevin Feige is using
spider-man 3 in Avengers 5 to write
spider-man out of the MCU that's not
exactly what's happening with the next
two spider-man movies what they'll do is
is they'll use spider-man 3 to close the
arc of his first new trilogy with Tom
hauled spider boy becoming spider-man
remember they were doing the Harry
Potter thing where you follow him
through years of high school until he
becomes a man they'll finish using
spider-man 3 to world build enough
spider-man universe characters so that
the next trilogy or a group of films has
a lot of places to go beyond just your
normal run-of-the-mill sinister 6 and
venom crossovers so we're talking
spider-verse Spider gettin clone saga
every big spider-man arc you could
possibly think of Sony doesn't want to
make three more spider-man films after
he's done in the MCU they want to make
1012 more spider-man films so use that
to go in a lot of different directions
in order to accomplish that right now
technically his last MCU film if that is
Avengers 5 we'll just tie off his arc
and leave room for him to return in the
next Avengers movie if they renew the
sharing contract which they will so
they're not gonna kill him off or
anything like that they're not gonna
give him the Captain America treatment
which basically means benching the
character by turning him into a super
old man really good example of this
would be Sony making spider-man 4
without Marvel but then spider-man
coming back to the MCU for Avengers 6
Secret Wars if both those companies can
set aside their differences like they
did in the past month after all those
terrible terrible headlines and people
going after each other of course they
can do it again Sony isn't gonna be
bought by Apple or Amazon Disney is not
going to buy the spider-man rights back
for ten billion dollars they'll just
work out a new contract one or two
movies at a time to keep the character
inside the MCU so what's gonna happen
next is is they get ready to shoot venom
2 in November because they've already
got the story for that film and it's
already overstuffed with a lot of venom
in setting up the carnage character they
barely set up the carnage character
during the first venom movie as Kevin
Feige says he's going to appear inside
the Sony venom movies in the Spidey
verse as he calls it so that's where you
get to venom to spider-man post-credit
scene referencing that character
creating a logical explanation
for why he would show up during venom 3
or if Sony really wanted to they could
do spider-man for maximum carnage if
they wanted to use spider-man in the
title of that movie it feels like if you
gonna put spider-man and venom in a
movie you would want to put both
spider-man and venom in the title of the
movie - I know I put that clip at the
beginning of this where Tom Hollands
like if we do a venom crossover then it
would have to be in the MCU because I'm
not leaving the MCU
well that was him during spider-man
homecoming days he's a couple years
older now and he probably has a much
deeper understanding of what Sony's
long-term plans are and what Marvel and
Disney's long-term plans are for his
character so this doesn't mean that
venom will never come into the MCU it
just means for the next two films venom
isn't going to be in the MCU so just
remember that this is on a movie / movie
basis anything can change after that Tom
Hardy signed a contract for five venom
appearances obviously that I can make
five venom movies so that means that
probably venom trilogy and then two
other crossover films what those are
remain to be seen but clearly Sony wants
to do its own version of Avengers
infinity war in Avengers end game that
sounds like a spider versed movie and
it's gonna take them a while to build up
to something like that they have Morbius
coming out next summer we haven't seen
any footage for that yet but we should
get a trailer for it sometime early next
year if you haven't been reading
absolute carnage in the comics right now
it is also the nth degree of what a
carnage venom story could be it's
basically turning venom into one of the
biggest deepest characters in the Marvel
comics is fascinating and I hope someday
that they're able to do it in a movie
but the mythology of it all is so crazy
and big that it's gonna take them a long
time to get there and you can kind of
tell from Tom Hardy's early interviews
talking about spider-man crossover or
him being in the MCU
that when he initially signed his
contract they told him that venom was
probably gonna be on its own this was
still early days before they'd ever
worked out any sharing arrangement so
the way they started building out the
venom franchise is that it was built
with venom being the big spider-man
character venom is a big enough
character that you could do your own
infinity war style event with just venom
related stuff but putting spider-man in
it would be that much cooler so of
course they're going to try and do that
as fast as possible the really cool
thing about venom - now is that it seems
like they're filming it in London so
that they can get crazy
I think architecture to make it look
like old-world New York City so it seems
like they're trying to create the
circumstances that would explain why
spider-man might run in to venom inside
a movie but a lot of this is all just
based around the carnage character so
then and to mostly gonna be a carnage
movie I'm really excited to see what
Andy Serkis does with that movie they've
got a lot of talent behind it and I
think part of the reason for them
signing this contract with a spider-man
MCU stuff at the last minute is to get
people more hyped up about venom 2
because all this negative press is
terrible for both companies people
getting less excited about spider-man
movies because he's not in the MCU any
more people getting less excited about
MCU because it doesn't have spider-man
anymore but now with this big news bomb
he's still in the MCU and he's going to
cross over to the venom movies everybody
is just a little bit happier about it
all but your tinfoil hats on - because
of course there's a lot of conspiracy
theories about people at both companies
leaking information so that they could
use the press to negotiate a new sharing
arrangement everybody in Hollywood at
all levels the actors the agents the
Hollywood Studios do that all the time
there's a new Doctor Strange - Ghost
Rider video that I'm working on new
Black Widow I'll try to make those
videos as fast as possible leave all
your spider-man and venom video requests
in the comments below - congratulations
a little red star you're the giveaway
winner from my last big Marvel video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details
everybody click here to learn how Marvel
won spiderman back into the MCU and
click here for my brand-new deleted
spider-man far from home post credits
scene thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
spider-man is bad
[Music]